شركه ليوناردو الايطاليه اثبتت حضور كبير
بعد ما قدمت الكثير من المنظومات التي
تعاملت مع الانظمه البحريه والتي شكلت خط
دفاع ممثل بالنسبه للكثير من الدول على
مستوى العالم حول مشاركه ليوناردو
الايطاليه في يورونافال 2022 في باريس
معنا السيد باسكال دي بارتو لوميو رئيس
العمليات بشركه ليوناردو والايطاليه اولا
مصر باسكال اهلا بك معنا في عسكريه في هذا
المعرض كشفتم عن منظومه دي اس اس اي ار اس
تي اولا هي هذه المنظومه وكيف تتوقعون شكل
اقبال العملاء
ثانكيو تانكي فردوسوا بورتونيتي شكرا
لاداحه هذه الفرصه لي منظومه دي اس اس اي
ار اس تي التي اعلن عنها هي منظومه
طورناها مؤخرا وتمثل الجيل الجديد من
قدرات الاشعه تحت الحمراء وبدا الجيش
الايطالي في استخدامها على سفن الدوريات
والمروحيات الخفيفه وقد ابحرت سفن
الدوريات اليوم
وستستخدم في الخليج العربي ايضا وهذه
المنظومه تشمل قدرات اضافيه على توفير
الحمايه من التهديدات المختلفه فهي
تكنولوجيا حديثه ومتقدمه توصلنا اليها
بفضل الابحاث والتطوير التي قمنا بها على
مدى الاعوام لتحسين اداء القوات البحريه
حول العالم شركه ليوناردو من الشركات التي
قدمت الكثير من المدافع البحريه اولا هل
تاثر الطلب على المدافع البحريه خاصه في
ظل تصعد التوتر وكذلك وجود ده البحريه
كثيره تتعرض لها دول للعالم الان
شيرد ده اول كبابيليتي
مثل مدفع ليون فيش وعلى الجدار هناك مدافع
عيار 76 ملم
225 ملم وكل ها مدافع تاريخيه ذات ذخيره
موجهه وقادره على حمايه السفن المتحركه من
اي اهداف من الميداليات القصيره وصولا الى
الصواريخ المضاده للسفن التي تمثل حاليا
التهديد الاساسي للقوات البحريه حول
العالم
وحداتنا التاريخيه المعروفه باسم
اوتومالارا لا تزال فعاله وسنستمر في
تحديثها للمستقبل لاداره جميع التهديدات
البحريه في عام 2020 اطلقتم استراتيجيه
تمتد 10 سنوات هذه الاستراتيجيه كانت بهدف
تحقيق تكامل اوروبي في مجال الصناعات
الدفاعيه والعسكريه اولا اين وصلت هذه الى
استراتيجيه وكذلك هل تاثرت هذه
الاستراتيجيه خاصه بعد الحرب شكرا
اوكرانيا والتي اصبحت تهدد الكثير من
الدول الاوروبيه
السيد ليوناردو بوضوح عن ضروره تفكيرنا في
السنوات العشر المقبله وهدفنا هو عام 2030
والاطلاع الى المستقبل يعني الابتكار
والتكنولوجيا والابحاث والتطوير وراس
المال البشري وعلى وجه الخصوص الاستثمار
نحن نعمل جاهدين وقد طورنا وركبنا حاسوبا
عاليا الاداء وهو من اقوى الحواسيب عاليه
الاداء في العالم اليوم ومن بين افضل 20
او 10 حواسيب متخصصه في امن ودفاع الفضاء
الجويه كما طورنا 15 مختارا منتشره في
اوروبا والولايات المتحده وهي مخصصه
للذكاء الاصطناعي والتوامه الرقميه ولدينا
مواد جديده ومن اجل استخدام هذه المختبرات
فنحن مستمرون في توظيف اصحاب شهادات
الدكتوره القادرين على استخدام وتطوير هذه
المختبرات لصناعه منتجات المستقبل
الان الكثير من الدول في منطقه مثل منطقه
الشرق الاوسط لم تعد تسعه فقط لشراء
منظومات دفاعيه بل تسعى كذلك لتعزيز
صناعاتها في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه الى اي مدى شركه كبيره مثل شركه
ليوناردو مستعده ان تشارك التكنولوجيا
وتشارك المعرفه مع الشركات الناشئه في
منطقه مثل المنطقه الشرق الاوسط
ليونار
طويل
المنطقه القدرات البحريه والقوات المسلحه
الاخرى وما فعلناه في السنوات الاخيره
تمثل في التحول من نموذج الموردي للعملاء
الى نموذج شريك وهذا يعني تحويل
التكنولوجيا وتصنيع القدرات حسب
الاحتياجات المحليه حيث نستمر تعمل عملاء
والدعم اللوجستيه وبهذا نحن نميز بين
احتياجات عملائنا فبدلا من بيع المنتجات
الجاهزه نحن ندير عملياتنا في السوق
المحليه من خلال العثور على الشركاء
المحليين لكي نطور قدراتهم في بلادهم في
الوقت المحدد وبتكلفه متدنيه واداء على
الجوده